مشاهدينا ما هي جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه تعرف
الجبهه نفسها بانها قوه عمل تسعى لتشكيل
حكومه انقاذ وطني تخرج تونس من الازمه
السياسيه والاجتماعيه تاسست في مايو ايار
عام 2022 وهي تراسها احمد نجيب الشابي هي
تجمع قوى سياسيه معارضه للرئيس قيس سعيد
لمواجهه الاجراءات الاستثنائيه التي
اعلنها سعيد في يوليو تموز من عام 2021
تضم الجبهه حركه النهضه وتحالف قلب تونس
واتلاف الكرامه اضافه الى حركه تونس
الاراده وحزب امل وحملت مواطنون ضد
الانقلاب وعددا من البرلمانيين وغيرهم
فتم سوق الجبهه بدستور عام 2014 وتعتبره
المرجع الوحيده للشرعيه الدستوريه للبلاد
تهدف الجبهه الى استئناف المسار
الديمقراطي والدستوري وتوحيد صفوف
المعارضه لاسقاط ما تصفه بالانقلاب ومشروع
سعيد وتشكيل بديل ديمقراطي يؤسس لي
ديموقراطيه مستدامه ورسم خريطه انقاذ
لاستئناف المسار الدستوري اضافه الى ارساء
توافق وطني عبر حوار شامل يفضي الانتخابات
المبكره كما تهدف الجبهه الى التصدي
لمساعي السيطره على القضاء